[संगीत]
[प्रशंसा]
हेलो एवरीवन
गुड इवनिंग दोस्तों एक बार सबसे पहले आप
मुझे यह बता दीजिए की सबको मेरी आवाज सही
से सुने दे दिया नहीं दे रही
जल्दी से बता दीजिए उसके बाद हम कंटिन्यू
करेंगे स्टार्ट करेंगे अपने फर्स्ट दे को
ओके थैंक यू थैंक यू थैंक यू
पढ़ना के लिए
तो
ठीक है तब तक बाकी लोग ए जाते हैं मैं
अपने बड़े में बताता हूं कुछ मैं अपने
इंट्रोडक्शन देता हूं की वह
डिप्लोनिक साइबर सिक्योरिटी प्राइवेट
लिमिटेड कंपनी और
योर ट्रेनर अलसो इस कोर्स के लिए आपका
ट्रेन
तो वैसे तो इस कोर्स को बढ़ाने के लिए मैं
सच में बहुत एक्साइड हूं तो आज अच्छे लोग
स्टैंड भी हमारे सामने 24 लोगों तो मुझे
लगता है शायद हमें 1 मिनट और वेट करना
चाहिए ताकि अगर जिसको आना है ए जाए और आप
लोग भी जिनको जानते हैं आपको लगता है की
इनको आना चाहिए तो आप प्लीज एक मिनट सब को
लाइव क्लास का लिंक शेर कर दीजिए तो काफी
इंटरेस्ट आने वाला है
अपने लोकल ग्रुप में कहानी पर भी एक बार
शेर कर दीजिए हम 1 मिनट वेट करते हैं उसके
बाद स्टार्ट करते हैं कंटिन्यू
ठीक है तब तक हम कुछ बातें करते हैं बाकी
लोग भी ए जाएंगे हमारे साथ जुड़ जाएंगे तो
कोर्स में आगे बढ़ाने से पहले आप लोगों को
लेकर डिस्क्लेमर है या एक वार्निंग समझिए
की जो कोर्स है हमारा पूरा जो कैप्सूल
कोर्स है ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस का यह एक
एजुकेशन परपज के लिए ही है कोर्स अगर आप
इस कोर्स का उसे करके कोर्स में सीखने के
वो साड़ी चीज सीखने के बाद टेक्निक सीखने
के बाद
1 मिनट 1 मिनट
सॉरी पर डिस्टरबेंस तो फिर से बताता हूं
मैं यह डिस्प्ले
की गई नॉलेज को अगर किसी भी इलीगल तरीके
से उसे करने की कोशिश करते हो या किसी भी
प्रकार की मलेशिया एक्टिविटी करने की
कोशिश करते हो यार किसी को भी हनी पहचाने
की कोशिश करते हो तो प्लीज आप लोग यू आर
कॉम अंदर साइबर डॉ तो आपको इससे बहुत
ज्यादा नुकसान हो सकता है आपको एक बहुत
बड़ी अमाउंट का हो सकता है भुगतान करना पद
जाए अकॉर्डिंग तू साईं पल्ला और आपको जय
भी जाना पड़े तो प्लीज यह मेरी रिक्वेस्ट
है की जब यह कोर्स आपका एजुकेशन
लर्निंग परपज से बनाई हुई लैंप से ना की
किसी भी गलत परपज से उसे करने के लिए तो
प्लीज यह चीज आप लोग ध्यान में रखिए की आप
जो भी कुछ सीखोगे जी भी चीज के बड़े में
यहां जानोगे उसको किसी भी
अनइंटेंशनली आपको क्या है कहानी पर भी
उसको उसे नहीं करना है आपको किसी भी
प्रकार से मलेशिया से एक्टिविटी परफॉर्म
नहीं करनी है किसी भी अपने दोस्त अपने
फ्रेंड या एवं अपनी गर्लफ्रेंड किसी को भी
आपको उसे प्रकार के हनी पहचाने की कोशिश
नहीं करनी है अगर आप लोग फिर भी जानबूझकर
किसी को हनी पहचाने की कोशिश करते हैं तो
यह डेफ्रॉनिक्स सिक्योरिटी जो कंपनी है
उसकी तरफ से समझ लीजिए की हम किसी भी
प्रकार का कोई भी सपोर्ट प्रोवाइड नहीं
करेंगे बल्कि हमें जो हेल्प करनी होगी
अकॉर्डिंग
किसी भी
टाइप की अगर एक्टिविटी परफॉर्म करने की
कोशिश करता है तो प्लीज यह चीज आप लोग
अपने ध्यान में रखिए
क्योंकि यह कोर्स बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट कोर्स
है और इसमें बहुत साड़ी चीज हैं तो कुछ
इंपॉर्टेंट अनाउंसमेंट से रिलेटेड आपके
लिए अभी बात कर लेते हैं बाकी लोग इसके
बाद 39 लोग हैं इसके बाद तो बाकी मुझे
लगता है की नेक्स्ट क्लास से दिखेंगे नहीं
दिखेंगे क्योंकि लोग पता नहीं पहले क्लास
में दिखाई देते हैं उसके बाद दिखाई देते
हैं तो
अपने ग्रुप में पढ़ा होगा की अबकी बार आप
लोगों के लिए एक स्पेशल ऑफर यह है की
इस कोर्स के दौरान 10 दिन का कोर्स रहेगा
10 दिन से अगर जा ये डिपेंड करता आप लोगों
के ऊपर अगर जल्दी से ऊपर जाना है तो आप
लोग जितना इंटरेस्ट दिखाओगे इस हिसाब से
कौन चलेगा तो
इसमें क्या है की आप लोगों की ट्रैकिंग ऑफ
योर अटेंडेंस आपकी अटेंडेंस को ट्रैक किया
जाएगा जो लोग स्टार्टिंग से दे वन से लेकर
हमारे और कोर्स और होने तक जो रहेगा एक
उसे चीज को मॉनिटर किया जाएगा दूसरा इस
कोर्स में जो भी कुछ सीखोगे जी बी
पर्टिकुलर वीडियो में जो भी कुछ सीखोगे
आपको जहां भी कमेंट करने के लिए बोला
जाएगा इस कोर्स में क्योंकि टोटली कोर्स
इस फ्री है तो अब इतना तो हमारा हक बंता
है की आप लोगों को इस चीज के लिए फोर्स
करें तो आपको क्या करना है की जो भी आपको
बोला जाएगा कोर्स में जो भी आपको सिखाया
जाएगा तो उसको क्या करना है आपको आगे एन
नोट्स फ्री पर करना है उसे नोट्स को ऐसे
ऐसे बनोगे जैसे वो कोई रिपोर्ट लिख रहे
हैं आपने जो स्टेप सीखे जो स्टेप आपने उसे
पे खुद से परफॉर्म किया वो साड़ी चीज जैसे
ही हम अभी तक खाली नहीं इसकी जो कोर्स में
रहे होंगे तो वैसे ही आपको क्या है की
वहां पर लिंकडइन वेब पेज पर जाना है और
वहां पर आप जो कमेंट में वो साड़ी चीज
वहां पर कमेंट करोगे तो वहां से भी हम आप
लोगों को मॉनिटर करेंगे की कौन क्या सिख
रहा है किसने किस टाइप की नॉलेज लिए है
किसने क्या शिखा है भारत में किसको क्या
समझ आया इस कोर्स में ये साड़ी चीज तीसरी
सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट चीज जो आपके ट्रैक की
जाएगी वो है की
आपको भी इस कोर्स के बीच में असाइनमेंट
दिया जाएगा इस कोर्स के बीच में आपको क्या
दिया जाएगा असाइनमेंट दिया जाएगा
इस कोर्स के बीच में आपको असाइनमेंट दिया
जाएगा उसे असाइनमेंट के बेस पर क्योंकि एक
वो आपको पहले से ही एक ऐसा असाइनमेंट दिया
जाएगा उसको उसके बेस पर आपको क्या करना है
एक रिपोर्ट राइटिंग करनी है उसके ऊपर एक
अच्छी रिपोर्ट राइटिंग जितनी अच्छी है आप
उसमें रिपोर्ट राइटिंग कर सकते हैं जितना
था उसे पर
% आप उसे कर पाएंगे
वो रिपोर्ट राइटिंग करने के बाद वो
इनफॉरमेशन कैसे आप लोग हमको प्रोवाइड
करेंगे कैसे आप लोग वो अंतर डॉग ये आपको
बता दिया जाएगा और उसके बीच में ये तीन
चीज आपके बड़े में ट्रैक की जाएगी उसके
बेस पर हम आप लोग में से एक किसी भी एक
इंसान को हम क्या करेंगे चीज करेंगे किसी
भी स्टूडेंट को चूज देंगे उसको हम अपने
डेफ्रॉनिक्स की शर्ट प्रोवाइड करेंगे उसको
गेम प्रोवाइड करेंगे सर कम्युनिकेशन कैसे
होगा वो आपको बता दिया जाएगा और ये
एनालाइज सर जैसे ही कोर्स खत्म हो जाएगा
एक दो दिन के अंदर ये पूरा एनालाइज हो
जाएगा और उसको पर्सनली कम्युनिकेट हम
करेंगे लिंक देना अकाउंट पर तो प्लीज
जिसका भी लिंक देना अकाउंट नहीं है वो नोट
4 कॉस्ट परपज ओनली आप कस के परपज लिंकडइन
अकाउंट ना बनाएं लिंकडइन अकाउंट बनाना
इसलिए जरूरी है अगर आपको जब करनी है कहानी
भी वहां भी आपका लिंक देना अकाउंट देखा
जाता है तो लिंक दें अकाउंट में जो भी आप
जो भी कोर्स करते हैं जो भी आप
सर्टिफिकेशन करते हैं वो उसमें आप एड करते
जाइए लिंकडइन अकाउंट में प्रोफाइल बनाई है
उसको तो प्लीज अपना लिख देना अकाउंट
क्रिएट कीजिए और उसके थ्रू ही आना आपको
कांटेक्ट करेंगे तो ये एक इंपॉर्टेंट
अनाउंसमेंट थी कोर्स में आगे बढ़ाने से
पहले तो अब काफी लोग हैं 41 लोग हैं तो
काफी अच्छा ग रहा है
तो अब मैं बात करते हैं फिर हम अपना पोस्ट
के साथ आगे बढ़ते हैं तो पोस्ट स्टार्ट
करते हैं अभी पोस्ट स्टार्ट करने की बड़ी
है अभी चलो स्टार्ट करते हैं ओके आर यू
एक्साइड सभी एक्साइड हमारे साथ कोर्स करने
के लिए अभी और इतने लोग अगर डेली हमारी
लाइव क्लास में ए जाएंगे तो फिर तो यह मजे
ए जाएंगे मुझे भी पढ़ना का बहुत मजा आएगा
ऐसे अगर आप सपोर्ट करोगे तो मुझे बहुत
ज्यादा मजा आएगा पढ़ना में
है तो बात करते हैं की यह जो ओपन सोर्स
इंटेलिजेंस है जिसके बड़े में आज हम
डिस्कस करने वाले हैं यह क्या चीज है इसके
बड़े में
तो अभी एक डेफिनेशन आपके सामने दिखाई दे
रही होगी की ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस
माइथॉलजी और कलेक्टिंग एनालाइजिंग मेकिंग
डिसीजन अबाउट डी डाटा एक्सेसिबल इन
पब्लिकली अवेलेबल सोर्सेस डेटम ओपन रेफर
तू पब्लिकली अवेलेबल सोर्सेस अभी मैं
डेफिनेशन पर नहीं जाता इस डेफिनेशन
पर आएंगे देखो सबसे पहले यहां पर सवाल
अब अन्योन का मतलब क्या है
लिस्ट हो चाहे आप एक एथिकल हैकर हो चाहे
आप एक ब्लैक हैकर हो चाहे आप एक फॉरेंसिक
एक्सपर्ट हो चाहे आप एक थ्रेड इंटर हो
चाहे आप एक इंसिडेंट रिस्पांडर हो चाहे आप
एक बौंती हूं या आप कुछ भी हो कहानी पर आप
जब कर रहे हो चाहे आप एक नॉर्मल इंसान हो
आप टेक्निकल हो नॉन टेक्निकल हो या आप
क्या है की आ एवं हमारे पेरेंट्स भी अन्य
वन में पेरेंट्स भी आते हैं सबके लिए अब
इन सबके लिए ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस क्या है
इसकी इंर्पोटेंस क्यों है अब मैंने क्यों
इतने नाम लिए और क्यों
आप टेक्निकल हो या नॉन टेक्निकल हो सभी के
लिए इंपॉर्टेंट क्यों है इसके बड़े में
जानना है क्यों चाहिए क्या चीज है
जो किसी को नहीं पता बस नाम सुना है उसके
बड़े में किसी को नहीं पता ऐसे क्या चीज
है
अब देखो यह सब चीजों का जवाब चाहिए
यू नो
यू नो दिस आंसर दें ओनली यू अंडरस्टैंड और
वही इट्स इंपॉर्टेंट देखो
समझना से पहले हमें एक इंपॉर्टेंट सवाल के
ऊपर बात करनी होगी बहस करनी होगी उसके ऊपर
डिस्कस करना होगा वो क्या है की कोई भी एक
हैकर है या जो अटैक है वो कैसे आपकी
सिस्टम को हैक कर पाते कैसे
अगर इस सवाल का जवाब आपको पता है
अच्छी तरह से समझ पाओगे की एक हैकर कैसे
यह सब आपको मुझे एक ऑर्गेनाइजेशन को किसी
भी एक और ऑर्गेनाइजेशन कैसे वो हैक कर पता
है की सबसे पहले यहां पर सवाल उठाता है की
क्या सॉल्व होता है की कैसे एक हैकर को
पता है की सब कुछ इससे रिलेटेड किसी भी एक
व्यक्ति से रिलेटेड किसी भी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
उसके बड़े में इतनी इनफॉरमेशन कैसे पता है
देखो क्या होता है की मैं आपको एक
एग्जांपल देता हूं किसी भी
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन को किसी भी परसों को किसी भी
पर्सनालिटी को या कोई भी हो किसी को भी
हैक करने के लिए सबसे पहले उसके बड़े में
जानना बहुत जरूरी है जब तक हमें उसके बड़े
में नहीं पता तब तक हम उसको हैक नहीं कर
सकते अब वह इनफॉरमेशन वह उसके बड़े में
जानना है जैसे की उसका नाम वह कहां राहत
है क्या करता है क्या उसका यूजर नाम है
क्या उसके सोशल मीडिया अकाउंट्स हैं क्या
उसको पसंद है कौन सी उसके पास गाड़ी है
कहां वह जाता है
क्या
यह साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन क्या उसका ईमेल एड्रेस
है क्या उसका मोबाइल नंबर
यह साड़ी चीज जब तक किसी एक्टर को नहीं
पता वह उसको अटैक नहीं कर सकता वह उसको
फेक नहीं कर सकता यह साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन कोई
भी हैकर को पता हनी चाहिए किसी को भी अटैक
करने के लिए अब
बोला की यह इनफॉरमेशन हैकर के पास आई कहां
से यह इनफॉरमेशन आई कहां से हैकर के पास
तो अब बात करते हैं
की यह साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन किसी के बड़े में
किसी को कैसे पता चलती
के लिए जो सबसे पहले स्टेप होता है मैं
अगर आपको
वैसे तो अभी मुझे यहां पर कुछ लिखने की
जरूर है नहीं सब बटन वाली बातें हैं तो
बातें ही करनी पड़ेगी हमें तो किसी भी
हैकर के लिए या किसी भी अटैक के लिए सबसे
पहले जो स्टेप होता है ना वो होता है आपका
इनफॉरमेशन गैलरी गैदरिंग डी इनफॉरमेशन यह
होता है
किसी भी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के बड़े में जितनी
इनफॉरमेशन वह कलेक्ट कर सकता है वह कलेक्ट
करें वह साड़ी चीज वह सबसे पहले स्टेप
होता है किसी भी हैकर के लिए इनफॉरमेशन
गैदरिंग जो सबको पता है
अब अगला सवाल
तो यह सब पॉसिबल है बिकॉज़ ऑफ ओपन सोर्स
इंटेलिजेंस बिकॉज़ ऑफ ओपन सोर्स
इंटेलिजेंस जिसको हम बोलते हैं
एक दरिया है एक ऐसा समुद्र जहां पर
इनफॉरमेशन पड़ी हुई है अब बोलोगे जब इतना
बड़ा दरिया है समुद्र है इनफॉरमेशन है तो
फिर भी हम इनफॉरमेशन गदर क्यों नहीं कर
पाते देखो क्या है ना की इस ओसियन से
इनफॉरमेशन निकालना के लिए अलग-अलग स्टेप्स
होते हैं अलग-अलग मेथाडोलॉजी होती हैं
सबकी अपनी-अपनी होती हैं अपने अपने तरीके
होते हैं तो ठीक उसे क्वेश्चन से
इनफॉरमेशन निकाल शक्ति है और यहां पर कोई
गारंटी नहीं होती की उसे ओसियन में वो
इनफॉरमेशन निकाल ही जाए हो सकता की वो
इनफॉरमेशन
आपके सामने अवेलेबल है या वह इनफॉरमेशन
आपके
से हायड कर दी गई है छुपा दी गई है यह भी
हो सकता है पब्लिक को प्राइवेट नाम की भी
चीज होती हैं इस क्वेश्चन के अंदर तो अब
बात करते हैं की यह ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस
है क्या चीज लोगों को मालूम ही नहीं है की
ओपन सोशल इंटेलिजेंस है क्या बस सबको पता
है मुझे सीखना है बट नहीं पता लोग
इंटर्नशिप भी कर रहे हैं किसी को यह नहीं
पता की ओपन सोशल इंटेलिजेंस है क्या
इंटेलिजेंस क्यों इतनी इंपॉर्टेंट है किसी
भी एक ऐसे इंसान के लिए जिससे बस
सिक्योरिटी की ए बी सी तक नहीं पता चलो
फिर अब आते हैं बैक तू अवर स्लाइड जो पहले
स्लाइड थी हमारी की ओपन 100 इंटेलिजेंस
क्या है मैंने यहां पर क्या लिखा है की
ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस इस ए मल्टी स्टेप्स
माइथॉलजी पर कलेक्टिंग एनालाइजिंग मेकिंग
डिसीजन
ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंट मतलब क्या है की वह
साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन जो पब्लिकली अवेलेबल है
जिसको कोई भी पढ़ सकता है वो आई है ओपन
सोर्स इन इनफॉरमेशन के अंदर जो आपकी
पब्लिक के लिए है जिसे कोई भी पढ़ कर पढ़
सकता है तो इसको कलेक्ट करने के लिए इस
इनफॉरमेशन को क्या करने के लिए हम क्या
करते हैं कलेक्ट करने के लिए इस अवेलेबल
इनफॉरमेशन को हम उसे करने के लिए या
ज्यादा से ज्यादा इस इनफॉरमेशन निकालना के
लिए हम कुछ स्टेप्स परफॉर्म करते हैं क्या
करते हैं कुछ स्टेप्स परफॉर्म करते हैं
समझे की ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस का उसे करके
हम और इस इनफॉरमेशन को गदर करने के लिए
स्टेप्स का उसे करके हम किसी भी टारगेट की
एग्जिट इनफॉरमेशन निकाल सकते हैं
हम सीखने हैं कैसे किसी भी टारगेट के बड़े
में इनफॉरमेशन को कलेक्ट करना है
कैसे उसको एनालाइज करना है और उसके बेसिस
पर हम डिसाइड करते हैं की यह इनफॉरमेशन
सही है या गलत है
अब सवाल यह उठाता है की ओपन सोर्स
इंटेलिजेंस क्यों
यहां पर फिर से ए गया
इनफॉरमेशन सिक्योरिटी
के लिए अब यह इनफॉरमेशन सिक्योरिटी क्या
होती है अब इनफॉरमेशन सिक्योरिटी का मतलब
होता है
जो वह अपलोड नहीं हनी चाहिए अगर वह
इनफॉरमेशन अगर वह इनफॉरमेशन अपलोडेड है
उसे प्लेटफॉर्म पर तो मुझे उसको कैसे
सिक्योरिटी करना है यह आता है इनफॉरमेशन
सिक्योरिटी के अंदर बेसिकली ओपन सोर्स
इंटेलिजेंस इसलिए बनाया गया था जो उसे
किया जाता है 17 साइबर सिक्योरिटी
इंजीनियरिंग के द्वारा किसी भी
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन को सीकर करने के लिए बट क्या
है की अब लोगों ने ओपन सोशल इंटेलिजेंस का
क्या है की जो अटैकर्स है ब्लैक है
एक्टर्स हैं उन्होंने इसको गलत तरीके से
उसे करना शुरू कर दिया है लोगों को नुकसान
करने के लिए शुरू कर दिया है और मैं क्यों
बार-बार बोल रहा हूं की ये ओपन सोर्स
इंटेलिजेंस है इसको हर किसी को पता होना
चाहिए क्योंकि आपको ये पता होना चाहिए की
अटैकर हैकर कैसे आपसे वो इनफॉरमेशन क्रैक
करते हैं
अगर आपको पता होगा तो ही आप अपने आप को
प्रोटेस्ट कर पाओगे बेसिकली क्या है इसका
मतलब क्या है की मैं बार-बार बोल रहा हूं
की आप अपने आप को प्रोटेस्ट करना चाहते
हैं तो कैसे आप प्रोटेस्ट कर सकते हैं कौन
कैसे स्टेप ले सकते हैं जब आप इस टाइप की
बचाना चाहते हैं क्योंकि आपको ऐसी चीज
देखने को मिलेगी जो आप सुनिए क्योंकि हमें
पता है की हमें ये लगता है की या या मेरी
क्या इनफॉरमेशन पब्लिक कोई मेरे को क्यों
हैक करेगा मेरे पास तो कोई इनफॉरमेशन है
ही नहीं
कोई क्यों मेरे को हैक करेगा या वह लोग जो
ज्यादा सोशल मीडिया पर एक्टिव
इंटेलिजेंस अब अगला सवाल होता है आता है
की व्हाट टाइप ऑफ इनफॉरमेशन
किस टाइप्स की इनफॉरमेशन हम गदर करते हैं
अब मैं यूजर पर्सपेक्टिव से आता हूं की
कौन सी टाइप की वो इनफॉरमेशन
ए जाते हैं उसके सोशल मीडिया अकाउंट्स अब
प्रोफाइल्स में हम क्या-क्या
पसंद है क्या नहीं पसंद है आपने कहां तक
एजुकेशन की है कहां से आपने एजुकेशन की है
आप कितना टाइम एक्टिव रहते हैं कितना टाइम
एक्टिव नहीं रहते आप कहां पर जाना आपको
पसंद है आपकी कमजोरी क्या है आपके वीकनेस
क्या है आपके इमोशंस क्या है वो सारे यहां
पब्लिक इनफॉरमेशन के प्रोफाइल के अंदर आते
हैं वह कहां आते हैं आपके प्रोफाइल फाइल्स
के अंदर आते हैं
इमोशंस कैसे पता चला है
की सबका पता है की जैसे खुश रहते हैं
अच्छे-अच्छे स्टोरी डालते हैं इंस्टाग्राम
पे अच्छे-अच्छे स्टोर लगाते हैं जब हमारे
साथ कोई प्रॉब्लम क्रिएट होते हैं सब
स्टोरी डालते हैं दूसरे को ओके अब यह क्या
सेट है वहीं पर क्या है किसी को भी पसंद
नहीं है तो उसे चीज को हम डिसलाइक करते
हैं या उसमें डालना पसंद नहीं करते और हम
कुछ भी पसंद करते हैं जैसे मुझे कोई
डॉग पर फ्रूट पसंद है जो मुझे पसंद है वो
मेरे उसपे रहेगा मेरी लाइक्स में मेरी
कमेंट्स में रहेगा या मेरी स्टोरी में
रहेगा ओके आज मैंने ये खाया उसके बाद मैं
ऑफिस से निकाला बहुत ही ज्यादा होती है की
मैं ऑफिस से गया ये सेल्फी लिया की आई एम
सेलिब्रेटिंग दिस आई एम ये अब ये मैं ये
कर रहा हूं अब ये मैं कर रहा हूं सोशल
मीडिया इन्फ्लुएंस है की बात कर रहा हूं
इस्पेशली ज्यादातर तो ये साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन
कहां से है प्रोफाइल से आप सब कुछ तो बता
रहे हो
क्योंकि कोई हैकर मुझे हैक कैसे कर लगा
कोई भी हैकर मुझे हैक कैसे कर लगा वो
साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन कहां से ए रही है यही से
ए रही है क्योंकि आप उसे कहकर कोई
इनफॉरमेशन प्रोवाइड कर रहे हो
हैकर आपसे आपके पास जबरदस्ती नहीं कर
लेकिन वह इनफॉरमेशन आप दे रहे हो तब आपको
कब आप रोटी हो कब आप हंसते हो कहां आप
जाना पसंद करते हो क्या आप करते हो आपका
नाम क्या है एवं आपके फ्रेंड कौन से हैं
और वो फ्रेंड कमेंट करके और भी कम आसन कर
देते हैं की ओके इसका कैरेक्टर क्या है
इसको किस चीज से डर लगता है उससे और भी
अच्छा पता चल जाता है अब बात आते हैं की
इनफॉरमेशन रिलेटेड तू प्लेटफॉर्म से
रिलेटेड इनफॉरमेशन की बात करते हैं जैसे
की आ कोई भी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन की बात ए जाते
हैं तो हर एक ऑर्गेनाइजेशन की अपनी एक
वेबसाइट होती है या कोई भी एक ऐसा व्यक्ति
जो आ सेलिब्रिटी है वो कुछ ना कुछ कहानी
ना कहानी कम करता है तो उसकी खुद की एक
अपनी वेबसाइट होती है उसकी खुद की अपनी एक
वेबसाइट होती है तो उसे वहां पर किस टाइप
की इनफॉरमेशन करते हैं की उसका डोमेन नाम
क्या है उसका होस्ट नाम क्या है उसके
शब्दों मेंस क्या है उसके अंदर कौन-कौन सी
उसने हेडल्स फाइल छुपा राखी है उसके अंदर
उसके बाद आईपी एड्रेस पता करने के उसके
इंटरनल आईपी एड्रेस उसका एक्सटर्नल आईपी
एड्रेस या फूल रेंज ऑफ उसके आईपी एड्रेस
उसके बाद सॉफ्टवेयर
ड्राइविंग करते हैं आस की इनफॉरमेशन लेते
हैं की कौन-कौन सी वो टेक्नोलॉजी को उसे
कर रहे हैं कौन सा वो आस का वर्जन उसे कर
रहे हैं किस टाइप का वो आस है या कौन सा
वो आस है किस टाइप की वो सर्विस प्रोवाइड
कर रही है वो कंपनी किन सर्विसेज को कम कर
रही है क्योंकि वो न्यूज़ के थ्रू भी हमें
पता चल जाता है और अब कंपनी उसको फॉलो भी
करते हैं उसके बाद किस्त कौन से टाइप्स के
फायरवॉल को फायरवॉल को उसे करते हैं
कौन-कौन सी फायरवॉल है की हमें अगर वहां
से पता तो उधर की फायर वाली उसे की जा रही
है तो कौन सी कंपनी की फायरवॉल है क्या वो
अब अपग्रेड फायर वाला है या नेक्स्ट
जेनरेशन फायरवॉल है वो साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन हम
क्या कर सकते हैं ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस से
पता करते हैं
दोस्तों की इनफॉरमेशन सब गैदरिंग करते हैं
हम वहां पर हमें क्या है
हम बल्लेबाबिलिटी का भी पता लगा लेते हैं
और इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग में सबसे पहले और
सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट स्टेप है इनफॉरमेशन
गैदरिंग है और
जिसमें सबसे में इंपॉर्टेंट रोल प्ले करता
है आपका ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस
और ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस क्या है एक ओसियन
है मैंने बताया आपको एक ऐसा ओसियन जिसमें
भर-भर के इनफॉरमेशन दी गई है तो मुझे अब
लगता है की जिन लोगों को यह नहीं पता था
की ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस होता क्या है जिन
लोगों को लगता की मैं मुझे क्यों सीखना
चाहिए मैं एक नॉन्टे हूं या मुझे कोई
आइडिया नहीं हो पांचो इंटेलिजेंस का या
मुझे कुछ नहीं पता ओपन जीरो तो अब आप
लोगों को आइडिया ग गया होगा की ओपन सोर्स
इंटेलिजेंस हर एक इंसान को क्यों सीखना
चाहिए
अगर आप चाहे तो कमेंट में करके बता सकते
हो की आप लोगों को ओपन 100 इंटेलिजेंस के
बड़े में पता चल गया की अब यह ओपन सोर्स
इंटेलिजेंस होती क्या है किस चीज का नाम
ओपन सोशल रिलिजन बार-बार ग्रुप में कमेंट
आए थे की सर इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग सिखाओगे
क्या यही है वो इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग जो आप
लोग करते हो और इस चीज की मैं गारंटी देता
हूं की अगर आपको
ओपन सोशल इंटेलिजेंस नहीं आई अगर आप एक
साइबर सिक्योरिटी इंजीनियर हो तो आप उसे
फील्ड को छोड़ दीजिए मैं बोल रहा हूं
क्योंकि इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग जब तक आपको
नहीं आएगी और उसे इनफॉरमेशन किसके बेस पर
होती है ओपन सोशल इंटेलिजेंस के बेस पे
होती है ओसियन टेक्नोलॉजी के बेस भी होती
है तो माइथॉलजी के बेस पे होती है जब तक
वो टेक्निक्स आपको आई नहीं ओसियन आपको आता
नहीं तो आप कैसे किसी चीज के बड़े में
पेंटेस्ट कर सकते हो गैस कर सकते हो उसे
चीज के बड़े में आगे बाढ़ सकते हो तो
इसलिए जिसको ओपन सोशलिज्म नहीं आई ये
फर्स्ट स्टेप होता है किसी भी पेन
टेस्टिंग फील्ड का किसी भी फील्ड का या
सबको पता है की यह होता है आपका फर्स्ट
स्टेप होता है अगर आपको यह फर्स्ट स्टेप
ही नहीं आता तो आप सेकंड थर्ड स्टेप पे
जाके क्या करोगे क्योंकि आपके पास
इनफॉरमेशन है ही नहीं उसे चीज के बड़े में
तो ये है ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस मैं फिर से
बोल रहा हूं की ये सब सिक्योरिटी परपज से
है ओपन 100% कोई भी यहां पर किसी भी
प्रकार की इस कोर्स में जो भी इनफॉरमेशन
कलेक्ट करेगा मिस उसे नहीं करेगा किसी को
भी हनी पहचाने की कोशिश नहीं करेगा
प्लीज आप लोगों से रिक्वेस्ट है एडरवाइज
आप लोगों ने आप लोगों इसके लिए बहुत कड़ा
भुगतान करना पद सकता है जिसकी आप लोगों ने
उम्मीद नहीं की होगी क्योंकि साइबर डॉ हर
चीज पर अप्लाई होते हैं और आप इतनी ज्यादा
ट्रबल में पद जाओगे आप लोगों को समझ में
नहीं आया की मैं क्रिकेटर नहीं पद गया हूं
ओके और हम उसके लिए हेल्प नहीं करेंगे अगर
आपने ऐसा कुछ करने की सोच भी तो इस कोर्स
के बाद ये आज वीडियो क्या बेसिकली इंट्रो
वीडियो रहेगा अब मैं आपको दिखता हूं की अब
इस ओपन सोर्स इंटेंस की वजह से किसी की
जान भी जा शक्ति है आप लोगों लगता है ना
की मैं अगर आज ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस सीखना
हूं उसके बाद मैं क्या करता हूं की यह
सीखने के बाद की अब मैं कुछ भी
कर लूंगा अब मैं आपको एक ऐसा एग्जांपल एक
ऐसी स्टोरी बताने जा रहा हूं जो
बहुत ही दर्दनाक है और बहुत ही एक ओपन सोच
इंटेलिजेंस के बेस पर पुरी ओपन सोर्स
इंटेलिजेंस के बेस पर है जिसकी वजह से
आपने सोचा भी नहीं होगा की एक ऐसा क्राइम
हो सकता है किसी की जान भी जा शक्ति है अब
उन सब लोगों को के लिए वो है जो लोग ये
बोलते हैं ना की मैं एक सोशल मीडिया
इनफ्लुएंसर हूं मैं एक ऐसा बड़ा आ सोशल
मीडिया प्लेटफॉर्म रन करता हूं मैं हर
टाइप की इनफॉरमेशन डालता हूं और ये बोलना
है की मेरी परमिशन के बिना कोई मेरा कुछ
नहीं कर सकता जो बोलना हूं की मेरी परमिशन
के बिना मेरा कोई कुछ भी नहीं कर सकता मैं
अपना कैसा भी फोटो डालो या कोई भी लोकेशन
में डालू कुछ भी मैं अपलोड करूं तो कोई भी
मेरा विदाउट मी परमिशन कुछ भी नहीं कर
सकता जिनको ऐसा लगता है
वो या तो उनकी आंखें बैंड हो राखी है या
उन्हें पता ही नहीं की कैसे क्या होता है
ऐसा एग्जांपल दिखाए जा रहा हूं जिसमें
आपको पता चलेगा की हम डेली बेसिस पर
क्या-क्या गलतियां करते हैं
ये बात है आपकी
19 फरवरी 2020 की अराउंड 4:30 a.m
मॉर्निंग
[संगीत]
शॉट
करोगे की तो इसके बड़े में आपको पुरी
डिटेल रिपोर्ट मिल जाएगी
यह 18 साइज मैंने गलत दाल दिया
फरवरी
इंस्टाग्राम स्टोरी विद लोकेशन अब
उन्होंने क्या किया है की वो 18 फरवरी को
11:00 बजे के आसपास कैलिफोर्निया में लैंड
करते हैं और उसके बाद क्या करते हैं की वो
अपनी इंस्टाग्राम पोस्ट को अपडेट करते हैं
स्टोरी को अपडेट करते हैं और एक
बैकग्राउंड में जहां पर वो लैंड करते हैं
जहां पर वो स्टे कर रहे हैं वहां पर जाते
हैं और वहां पर क्या है बैकग्राउंड में
उसे लोकेशन का फोटो दाल बैकग्राउंड मैं
उसे लोकेशन के साथ अपने फोटो के साथ विद
लोकेशन ऑन करके वो इंस्टाग्राम स्टोरी दाल
देते हैं
फिर अगला अपडेट करते हैं वे कुछ पोस्ट
अगेन अपडेट स्टोरी विथ नेक्स्ट पोस्ट ऑफ
हज गेटिंग हेयर कट अब कुछ दिन के बाद वह
क्या करते हैं एक्चुअल में क्या होता है
की वो वहां पर कर दिन के लिए अपना कुछ
हॉलीडे सेलिब्रेट करने गए थे कैलिफोर्निया
में हॉलीडे सेलिब्रेट कर रहे थे उसे टाइम
पे और फिर से वो क्या करते हैं की
कैलिफोर्निया में 18 फरवरी को लैंड करने
के बाद कुछ अराउंड 2 दिन के बाद ही वो फिर
से एक स्टोरी अपडेट कर अपडेट करते हैं
जब वो किसी भी बार-बार शॉप में हेयर कट ले
रहे थे वो बाल कटवा रहे थे तो वो हेयर कट
लेते हुए अपडेट करते हैं विद लोकेशन उसके
बाद फिर एक और पोस्ट में डालते हैं
ताल में अगेन वन मोर पोस्ट इन पुल विद
लोकेशन सो लाइक आईटी शेर लेट्स ऑफ फोटो अब
क्या है की फिर से क्या करते हैं नहाते
हुए एक पोस्ट डालते हैं की आई एम एंजॉयिंग
सो सो प्लीज उसके बाद क्या है की विद
लोकेशन एक और फोटोस क्या कर देते हैं
उसमें दाल देते हैं इंस्टाग्राम स्टोरी
में और इस तरीके से वो क्या है वो साड़ी
फोटो पे फोटो डालते जाते हैं की अब ये
इंस्टॉलमेंट तो मैं खाना का रहा हूं मैं
ये कर रहा हूं ये मैं स्विमिंग ताल है फिर
वो क्या है की आपने होटल रूम से क्या बैक
व्यू फ्रंट व्यू फिर उसके बाद होटल के
बाहर खड़ा हो गया ये वो व्यू या वो यू
व्यू क्या कर देते हैं वो क्या कर देते
हैं दाल देते हैं वो सारे फोटो दाल देते
हैं अभी तक कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं हुई थी
क्योंकि एक चीज नॉर्मल थी या साड़ी चीज
नॉर्मल चल रही थी अभी तक कोई भी ऐसी कोई
प्रॉब्लम वाली बात नहीं हुई
ठीक है
2 दिन की बात नहीं है वो थोड़ी सी क्या है
की मैं स्टोरी
है ये तो 18 फरवरी के हो के उससे पहले की
मैं जो दो दिन की बात बता रहा था मैं वो
बताया था स्पेंड कर रहे थे
तो उसके बाद क्या है की
साड़ी चीज नॉर्मल थी अब बाई मिस्टेक
नेक्स्ट पोस्ट उन्होंने क्या है की अगली
पोस्ट में एक मिस्टेक करते हैं गलत क्या
गलती करते हैं दे पोस्ट सम फोटोस वाइल्ड
ड्राइविंग कर इन विच मेकिंग होल सम कैश
डालते हैं उसके बाद जिसमें उनके हाथों में
क्या है उनके दोस्त थे माइक क्योंकि वो दो
दोनों साथ में थे तो माइक उनके एक दोस्त
है वो क्या करते हैं कुछ कैश के साथ क्या
करते हैं वो
फोटो दाल देते हैं की वह कुछ बंडल से
नोटों के बंडल फोटो डालते हैं
इस पोस्ट के बाद और उसे पोस्ट में दो
प्रॉब्लम थी दो वो गलतियां करते हैं पहले
क्या है फर्स्ट इन डी लेफ्ट कॉर्नर दे
एक्सपोज देवर होम एड्रेस उसे पोस्ट और
सेकंड दे अलसो
अब क्या जो पोस्ट डेल जाति है उसमें क्या
है की जो माइक है जो जिसके हाथ में कैसे
था वो फिर से उसे पोस्ट में क्या करता है
कर के सामने बैठ के खड़ा हो गए उतना ही
कैश लेक वो फोटो डलवात है और वो फोटो इस
तरीके से ली जाति है उसे फोटो में दो चीज
क्लियर होगी एक तो वो क्या सुन्नी के पास
है अभी तक दूसरा लेफ्ट कॉर्नर में जो उसका
होम एड्रेस था जहां पर वह अभिषेक रहा था
होटल में कुछ कर डिजिटल का एड्रेस था तो
तीन डिजिटल वहां पर एक्सपोज हो रही थी एक
डिजिटल था क्योंकि वो एक न्यूमैरिक वैल्यू
थी तो एक डील था तो वहां पर क्या है अगर
रूट पोस्ट करना भी होता है या गैस करना तो
एक से लेकर नो तक गेस्ट करना था
तो वापस एक एड्रेस
कर रहे थे रेंज रोवर तो ये तीन कर चीज
यहां पे और भी ज्यादा एक्सपोज होगी चलो एक
यहां से प्रॉब्लम स्टार्ट होगी नेक्स्ट
पेज पर चलते हैं
इंस्टाग्राम स्टोरी फिर से क्या करते हैं
की एक और वो पोस्ट डालते हैं इंस्टाग्राम
स्टोरी के ऊपर
डेथ शोइंग दे आर ड्राइविंग
कर रहे थे वहां पर क्या है की वो कर
ड्राइविंग
पोस्ट को फॉलो कर रहे हैं कंटिन्यूसली
क्योंकि वो एक्चुअल में क्या थे
चोर थे वह उसको फॉलो करें
अब क्या कर रहे थे उसके बाद जी दिन उनका
मर्डर हुआ था उसे रात को अराउंड 11:00 या
कुछ उन्होंने क्या एक वीडियो पोस्ट की उसे
वीडियो में क्या किया उन्होंने की जो
उन्होंने कुछ अपनी इस वेकेशन के दौरान
उन्होंने कुछ शॉपिंग की थी उसे शॉपिंग
आइटम्स को वीडियो में दिखा रहे थे और फिर
वह सम लेक जब सेंसेटिव इनफॉरमेशन अब जब वो
वीडियो में उन बॉक्स को दिखा रहे थे क्या
दिखा रहे थे उसको जो शॉपिंग के जो
बैग्स थे उनको दिखा रहे थे वहां पर एक
सेंसेटिव इनफॉरमेशन होती है
वहां पर की शॉपिंग बैग्स ऊपर टैग लगा हुआ
था जहां पर उसका क्या था एड्रेस था उससे
क्या हुआ उसका पूरा पूरा एड्रेस जो उसका
एड्रेस थोड़ा बहुत छुपा हुआ था तो वो पूरा
पूरा रिलीज हो गया और कंपलीटली वो क्या हो
गया
क्योंकि अब जो उसको फॉलो कर रहे थे लास्ट
के एक दिन से या दो दिन से उसको जो भी
फॉलो कर रहे थे उसकी इंस्टाग्राम पोस्ट को
उसके पैसों को उसके डायमंड रोलर्स को तो
उनको इतना तो पता चल गया की एक तो बड़ी
बड़े व्यक्ति है क्योंकि एक ये युटयुबर्स
है एक बहुत बड़ा रैपर है तो उसके पास इतना
सर पैसा है और डायमंड रिंग्स हैं ये साड़ी
चीज हैं ऊपर से कंटीन्यूअस वो अपनी हर
पोस्ट में कुछ ना कुछ बताया था ये मेरी
लोकेशन है यहां मैं राहत हूं उसके फूल
एड्रेस भी दे बिल हो गया ये साड़ी चीज
रिवील होने के बाद वो क्या किया
जो डेट रिपोर्ट थी उसकी जो
एक्सपोर्ट्स के लिए वो 530 का ग्राउंड
लेकिन क्या की 4:30 की उनकी लास्ट फोर्स
थी सोशल मीडिया पर और वहां पर क्या हुआ की
कर लोग आए नाइट में जब वो
अपने घर पर थे सोबर ले रहे थे उन्होंने
क्या किया उनके सर पे गांठ आनी वो सर कैश
मोबाइल सब कुछ लिया और उनको शॉर्ट कर दिया
उनको जान से मार दिया
जाए अगर कोई बोलेगा
ओसियन तो साइबर सिक्योरिटी अब जिन्होंने
यह कम किया ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस का
उन्होंने भी तो उसे किया ना तो वो तो कोई
साइबर सिक्योरिटी इंजीनियर नहीं थी वो
हैकर नहीं थे
उसे किया और किसी को जान से मार दिया तो
प्लीज
इंटेलिजेंस के इस तरह के कभी भी कोशिश मत
करना कभी भी किसी को हनी पहचाने की कोशिश
मत करना मेरा ये बताने का मतलब यह था की
ओपन 100 से इंटेलिजेंस इतनी डेंजरस है की
उसकी वजह से आप लोगों को किसी को भी हनी
हो शक्ति है और प्लीज यह कोर्स करने के
बाद यह साड़ी चीज सीखने के बाद आप लोगों
से रिक्वेस्ट है किसी को भी उसे इनफॉरमेशन
जब तक आपको परमिशन नहीं है जब तक आपको
अथॉरिटी नहीं है जब आपको रिटर्न परमिशन
नहीं है तब तक आप इसी प्रकार किसी भी
प्रकार की इलीगल एक्टिविटी करने की कोशिश
ना करें उसे इनफॉरमेशन के साथ तब तक लीगल
है इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग ओसियन तब तक लेकर है
जब तक आप उसे इनफॉरमेशन को देख रहे हो या
उसको पढ़ रहे हो या कलेक्ट कर रहे हो
लेकिन अगर उसे इनफॉरमेशन के साथ अगर कुछ
आपका गलत इंटेंशन है या किसी भी टाइप की
अगर आपकी गलत मानसिकता है कुछ भी करने की
अगर सोच रहे हो फिर वह इलीगल हो जाता है
विदाउट परमिशन किया गया फिर वो एक क्राइम
हो जाएगा अगर वो आप क्राइम करते हो तो
आपको मैं फिर से वन कर रहा हूं अगर से फिर
से वार्निंग दे रहा हूं की आप सीरियस
ट्रबल में पद जाओगे और आपको बूस्टबल से
कोई भी नहीं निकाल सकता वहां पे आपको बहुत
ज्यादा डैमेज आपकी फैमिली को आपको हो सकता
है तो प्लीज कप इन योर मन यह सब अपने
दिमाग में राजेश ये ट्रेनिंग सब एजुकेशन
देने के लिए है आप लोगों को अपने आप को
बचाने के लिए है की आप जो डेली बेसिस पे
कम करते हो की जिनको ज्यादा बोला की मैं
यह भी डालता हूं मैं खाता वक्त
इंस्टाग्राम पोस्ट डालता हूं या फेसबुक या
मैं अभी नहा रहा हूं या फिर ये घूम रहा
हूं मैं शॉपिंग कर रहा हूं अब मैं ये कर
रहा हूं ये सब वो चीज ही हैं जो किसी भी
इंसान को
ऐसी ट्रबल में दाल देते हैं तो यह लाइव
एग्जांपल था एक रियल स्टोरी स्टोरी है यह
इंस्टाग्राम सर्च कर सकते हो आपको पता चल
जाएगा ओके तो अब बात करते हैं
नेक्स्ट मैं आपको अब ये बताने जा रहा हूं
की कोर्स एक्चुअल में क्या है की हम आज
क्या की आपको बेसिकली अवेयर करना था की आप
जो चीज सीखने वाले हैं वो क्या चीज है मैं
वो सीखना चाहता था कोर्स एक्चुअल में जो
10 दिन का है 10 दिन पूरे होंगे आपको जो
आपका सिलेबस है मैं आपको देखा देता हूं की
अब मैं आपको दिखाने वाला हूं की आप इस
कोर्स के दौरान क्या-क्या सीखने वाले हैं
जो आप कमेंट जो आप सीखने आए हैं वो आप
क्या क्या सीखने हैं प्लीज लाइव सेशन
अटेंड करो बहुत कुछ सीखने का मिलेगा
रिकॉर्डिंग स्पेस डिपेंड मत हो क्योंकि हम
डाउट सेशन भी रखते हैं हम डाउट सेशन भी
रखते हैं
अब नेक्स्ट लेवल चला हूं यह आपका लिस्ट ऑफ
कंटेंट है जो इस कोर्स में पढ़ने वाले हैं
इस कोर्स में आप जो भी पढ़ने वाले हैं
इसके बड़े में आपको थोड़ा सा इंट्रो दे
देता हूं सबसे पहले आप पढ़ोगे की हो तू
उसे सर्च इंजन पर इनफॉरमेशन
अब देखो किसी भी सर्च इंजन का जो पहले पेज
आपको दिखाई देता है किसी भी सर्च इंजन
जैसे हम गूगल खोलने हो गूगल में क्या करते
हो की यहां पर मैंने लिया dafronics.com
मैंने अपनी ही वेबसाइट को ओपन किया है तो
यह आउटपुट में हमेशा आपको वो चीज दिखाई
देती है जो एक कंपनी आपको शो करना चाहती
है बेसिकली यहां फर्स्ट पेज पर हैकर के
लिए या हैकर्स रिलेटेड इनफॉरमेशन आपको
देखने नहीं मिलती एक कर को कोई भी
इनफॉरमेशन नहीं मिलती की जो उसको चाहिए
होती है फर्स्ट पेज पर
है तो हम क्या सिखाएंगे आपको एडवांस गूगल
सर्चिंग जिसको आप बोलते हैं
जिससे आप क्या कर सकते हो जो हैकर
पर्सपेक्टिव से यह जो इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग
पर्सपेक्टिव से जिसे आप क्या वो इनफॉरमेशन
निकाल सकते हैं जो आपको नॉर्मल पेज पर
देखने को नहीं मिलती जिसमें हम बहुत सारे
सर्च इंजंस का एग्जांपल जैसे की गूगल पे
या हो या इंडिक्ट सकता और भी हो सकते हैं
बी कोई भी जो सर्च इंजन है तो उनका कैसे
हम उसे करते हैं तो मतलब हम एडवांस सर्च
इंजन के बड़े में सीखने वाले हैं जिसको
आपने सुना होगा गूगल डोर किंग जिसको लोग
गूगल हैकिंग भी बोलते हैं बट उसका
एग्जैक्ट मतलब होता है
हम इमेज लेंगे उसके ऊपर इमेज एनालिसिस उसे
करेंगे इमेज को एनालाइज करने के कुछ
टेक्निक्स होती है तरीके होते हैं उसके
बाद उसे इमेज के बेसिस पर हम कैसे उसको
जिओ लॉकेट करेंगे कैसे हम उसको जिओ लॉकेट
करेंगे और एग्जैक्ट लोकेशन फाइंडर करने की
ये इमेज किसने ये इमेज ली होगी
कब यह ली होगी और कहां ये इमेज ली है क्या
उसके एग्जैक्ट कोऑर्डिनेटर हम फाइंड आउट
करने की कोशिश करते हैं विद डी हेल्प ऑफ
बहुत साड़ी चीजों के चीजों से हम क्या
करते हैं नेक्स्ट हम जो बात करेंगे थर्ड
चीज इसमें सीखेंगे
तो देखो अब कुछ ऐसी इनफॉरमेशन भी होती है
जिसमें हम कामायनी उसे करेंगे गूगल का
उसके बाद कुछ और ऐसे टूल्स होते हैं जिनकी
हेल्प से हम कोशिश करेंगे की किसी भी
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन की किसी भी पर्सनल की ईमेल
फाइंड आउट करने की मोबाइल नंबर की या उसका
कोई भी क्या इंटरेस्ट है उसकी पर्सनल
इनफॉरमेशन क्या है वो साड़ी चीज वो कुछ
उसको भी हम एक एडवांस परसेंट बोल सकते हैं
एडवांस एक टेक्निक बोल सकते हैं इसको भी
वो साड़ी चीजें भी हम क्या इसमें आपको कुछ
नया लेंगे जो ऑलरेडी आपकी लैब होगी तो
अवेलेबल है उन्हें का उसे करके हम यहां पर
आपको दिखाएंगे कहानी भी हम किसी को भी
यहां पर हनी नहीं पहचाने वाले किसी को भी
गलत तरीके से हम यहां पर उसे नहीं करने
वाले किसी भी ऐसे इंसान की हम वो
इनफॉरमेशन इसमें उसे नहीं करेंगे जिसको
कोई भी प्रॉब्लम हो नेक्स्ट
सोशल मीडिया
के ऊपर फेसबुक के ऊपर इंस्टाग्राम के ऊपर
इनका उसे करके आप कैसे ओपन सोर्स
इंटेलिजेंस कर सकते हैं एक अच्छे लेवल तक
जाएंगे कैसे उनको एडवांस तरीके से हम
इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग परपज से उसे कर सकते
हैं
जहां पर हम सबसे ज्यादा इनफॉरमेशन निकाल
सकते हैं वह जो इनफॉरमेशन जी जो
स्टार्टिंग से बात करें व्हेन वेयर यू की
आपके लाइक दिस लाइक आपकी प्रोफाइल पुरी
लाइफ की प्रोफाइल वो आपकी यहां से निकलते
है क्योंकि ये बहुत बड़ी चीज है सोशल
मीडिया ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस उसके बाद हम
परफॉर्म करेंगे
हमको परफॉर्म करेंगे वेबसाइट इंटेलिजेंस
उसके बाद हम सीखेंगे
तो क्या
यह बताइए किसी को पता है क्या
होता है
देखो क्या स्टैग एनर्जी
क्या होती है बताओ
इनफॉरमेशन बिहाइंड डी इमेज वीडियो ऑडियो
फाइल्स
किसी भी प्रकार की
इनफॉरमेशन कोड को हम क्या करते हैं किसी
इमेज के पीछे किसी भी वीडियो ऑडियो फाइल
के पीछे छुपा के हम किसी को डिलीवर कर
देते हैं उसको बोलते हैं हम स्टेनोग्राफी
होता है
तो उसके लिए आपको क्या करना पड़ेगा
दोस्तों यह आप लोगों का सिलेबस है जो आपकी
जो 10 डेज की जो है जी कैप्सूल कोर्स
इंटेलिजेंस की यह आपका यह फूल कोर्स है तो
जिसके थ्रू हम एक्चुअल में स्टेप वन से
स्टार्ट करेंगे हम कल से स्टार्ट करेंगे
हम आप लोगों को यह बताना चाहते थे की
इसके रेमेडियल या इसके ओपन सोशल होती क्या
है इसकी वजह से आपको क्या-क्या प्रॉब्लम
देखने को मिलती है रियल लाइफ एग्जांपल
आपके सामने रखा हुआ है और यह बहुत सारे जो
चीज थी जो वो शायद से आप लोगों के की जो
आप लोगों को लगता था की ये होता क्या जो
ग्रुप में आए थे मुझे लगता है की आप लोगों
के आप वो डाउट नहीं आने चाहिए तो अभी 10
मिनट के लिए हम आप लोगों को अगर आपको कुछ
भी अगर इसको से रिलेटेड कुछ जानना है की
हम क्या सीखने वाले हैं क्या डिस्कस करने
वाले हैं तो 10 मिनट है आप लोग मुझे कुछ
भी डाउट पूछ सकते हैं कुछ भी इसमें पूछ
सकते हैं
कोई भी कुछ पूछ सकता है अभी
आपको क्या लगता की हम क्या सीखने वाले हैं
या जो आपको उम्मीद है प्लीज आज भी जो
अटेंडेंस ऐसे मेंटेन करके रखिए तो आपको
बहुत बेनिफिट होना है क्योंकि हमने आप
लोगों का एक लिस्ट कोर्स के बाद ट्रेनिंग
के बाद आपकी एक ऐसे ट्रेनिंग स्टार्ट कर
दी है जो आपके धीरे-धीरे आपको क्या है की
नॉलेज को जेन करवाने में मदद करेगी
मतलब कुछ भी पूछ सकते हो आप लोग
गुड मॉर्निंग
सर ये और मेंटल को भी बोल रहा हूं
आई डिड नोट गेट की आप क्या पूछना छह रहे
हो मुझे समझ में नहीं आया ओके पूजा उसके
बाद यही है सर एक ग्रुप बना दो ना तो आप
लोगों को बताया गया है ना की ग्रुप में
जाकर आप
आप क्या कर सकते हो
प्लीज
आप कर सकते हो
एक मिनट
सॉरी
क्या था की एक ग्रुप देखिए आप लोगों पहले
बताया गया जब हमने अनाउंसमेंट ग्रुप
अनाउंसमेंट वीडियो डाली थी तो आप लोगों को
बोला था की इंस्टाग्राम हमारा ग्रुप है
हमारे लिंक के नीचे तो वहां पर जाकर आप
ग्रुप में एड हो जाइए आपको कर दें
नोटिफिकेशन सब कुछ वहां पर देखने को
मिलेगा तो जी आपका फूल नाम तो मुझे पता
नहीं लेकिन वो कोलगेट ही हमारा है
टेलीग्राम ग्रुप है तो वहां जाके आप जॉइन
हो सकते हो और वहां पर करते हो क्यों नहीं
कर सकते हैं उसे क्या क्योंकि लैब और रियल
लाइफ विच लैप्स उसे दिन दिस कोर्स डोंट
वारी ये आप लोग चिंता करने की जरूर नहीं
है आपको सब कुछ उसे करने को दिखाए जाएगा
वहां पे आपको कुछ टास्क भी दे देंगे सर
अन्य विजिट नॉलेज नो कोई भी आपको नॉलेज
नहीं है ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस में आपको
किसी भी प्रकार की कोई भी नॉलेज की जरूर
नहीं है पहले से ही बिल्कुल जीरो से ए
सकते हो आपको सबके लिए ये
सब अगर कोई टेलीग्राम पर ही है उसकी इसको
इनफॉरमेशन फाइंड कर सकते हैं क्या तो ब्रो
एक चीज बताइए जब आपको सोशल मीडिया
प्लेटफॉर्म पर नॉलेज मिल जाएगी तो
टेलीग्राम को तो ऑटोमेटेकली मिल जाएगी ना
टेलीग्राम आप क्या सोचते की ज्यादा
ओके तो उसके बाद है
नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट
पोषण का युद्ध इंटेलिजेंस में कैसे होता
है
इंटेलिजेंस का कैसे होता बताता हूं अब एक
थ्रेड इंटेलिजेंस एक ऐसी पुरी प्रोसेस
परफॉर्म की जाति है जहां पर रिस्क
मैनेजमेंट उससे पहले होता है राइट
इंटेलिजेंस रिस्क मैनेजमेंट का एक पार्ट
है तो रिस्क मैनेजमेंट करने के लिए
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन बहुत साड़ी चीजों को टर्म
मॉनिटरी किया जाता है उसमें क्या है की
बहुत सारे कीवर्ड है अगर आप लोगों को पता
है तो अच्छी बात है नहीं पता दो क्योंकि
आप किसी भी थ्रेड को डिटेक्टर करने के लिए
पहले क्या करते हो उसके बड़े में पब्लिकली
आयुषी इंडिया गेट रो कंप्रोमाइज के बड़े
में जानते हो एप्ट जो ग्रुप होते हैं जहां
पर मिटाया जैसे फ्रेमवर्क है वो क्या कम
करते हैं आपको ओपन 100 से इंटेलिजेंस का
कम करते हैं वो आपको जो इनफॉरमेशन अवेलेबल
है जो अटैक्स हो रहे हैं वो इनफॉरमेशन
आपको वहां पे प्रोवाइड की जाति है बहुत
सारे मिटाया फ्रेमवर्क है और भी है
2 दिन फ्रेमवर्क कैसे हैं जो आपको
इनफॉरमेशन तो रिस्क मैनेजमेंट में क्या
होता है की थ्रेड इंटेलिजेंस आई है और ओशन
का क्या रोल ए गया की आप क्या करते हो की
अगर किसी ने आपकी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन को अटैक
किया किसी भी किसी भी व्यक्ति ने किसी भी
परसों ने आपकी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन को अटैक किया
तो आप क्या करते हो की आपको पास क्या
इनफॉरमेशन आई है वहां पर या तो कोई और कोई
इनफॉरमेशन छोड़ गया होगा कोई आईपी मिल गया
आपको या उसका कोई नाम कुछ तो मिला होगा
उसके बेसिस पे आप क्या करते हो उसके बेसिक
एनालिसिस करते हो एनालिसिस कब करते हो या
तो पहले इस टाइप का कोई लोग जेनरेट हुआ है
या इस टाइप का कोई अलर्ट आया है या इस
टाइप का कुछ प्रॉब्लम हुई है या नहीं हुई
है ये उसके बाद
एनालिसिस क्या करते हैं क्या सोशल मीडिया
पर इसकी कोई इनफॉरमेशन अवेलेबल है क्या इस
टाइप का आईपी पहले से कहानी अटैक में उसे
किया गया है या कुछ और इनफॉरमेशन उसे आईपी
से रिलेटेड या उसे यूआरएल से रिलेटेड जो
आपको क्या है आपके रिस्क मैनेजमेंट या
इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस के दोनों आपको के दौरान
आपको मिलता है तो वह साड़ी चीज आप कहां से
कलेक्ट करोगे या अगर पूरा अटैक नया ही है
हो सकता है की किसी ने एक ऐसा अटैक किया
जो किसी भी टूल्स में किसी भी सी एम टूल
में या इडियट टूल में वाटर अवेलेबल नहीं
है कोई ऐसा अटैक सा बिल्कुल नया अटैक्स है
बिल्कुल नया ही मालवेयर रीड कर रहा है
बिल्कुल ही नया है तो वो कैसे उसको बेस पर
एनालिसिस करोगे वहां पर एनालिसिस आप ओपन
सोशल इंटेलिजेंस के बेस पे ही करोगे आपकी
जितनी स्ट्रांग ओपन सोस इंटेलिजेंस होगी
उतना स्ट्रांग आप एनालिसिस कर पाओगे आई हो
मुझे आपका
फर्श कुमार मैंने आपका जवाब दे दिया होगा
तो लाइव प्रैक्टिकल भी है क्या सर पूरा
प्रैक्टिकल है
पॉलीटिकल बहुत कम है
मोबाइल की लोकेशन ऑफ करके पिक कैप्चर किया
है फिर भी जिओ लॉकेट हो जाएगा क्या देखो
ब्रो अब जब इमेज एनालिसिस में बताएंगे अब
आप उसकी बात कर रहे हो की जो जिसने कोई
इनफॉरमेशन डाली ही नहीं है सोशल मीडिया पर
उसको कैसे ट्रैक करो अब मैं आप तो ऐसे ही
सवाल करोगे की कोई सी किसी इंसान ने अपनी
साड़ी प्रोफाइल फाइल्स पब्लिकली क्या कर
राखी है
ओन्ली प्राइवेट अकाउंट उसे कर रहा है वो
प्राइवेट है उसको एक्सपोज ही नहीं कर रहा
कभी कोई इसको करौली नहीं कर पाया या कोई
ऐसा इंसान हो सोशल मीडिया पर है ही नहीं
और वो क्या कर रहा है आपके जो मटर आता है
उसको क्या रिमूव कर दे रहा है तो फिर उसको
इसमें कैसे पॉसिबल है उसका मैंने क्या
बताया पब्लिकली वो इनफॉरमेशन अवेलेबल है
वो बोला मैंने अब ऐसे तूने
पीछे ग गए हो ऐसा नहीं है
एक्सपेरिमेंट हम नहीं कर सकते इस तरह के
रियल लाइफ किसी का सोशल मीडिया अकाउंट टेक
आउट नहीं कर सकते हैं ऑनलाइन भी किसी के
साथ भी एवं कोई भी नहीं कर सकता आकाश जी
पूजा जी सॉरी आप इस प्रकार का कोई भी नहीं
कर सकता आपको कहानी भी आप ट्रेनिंग करो तो
आपको लैब के ही प्रैक्टिस करनी पड़ती है
आप सोशल मीडिया पर किसी के ऊपर लाइव अटैक
नहीं कर सकते
हैं ओके सर इन दिस अलसो गेट तू नो हो तू
हायड अवर इनफॉरमेशन इंटरनेट
जी काफी हेल्प मिलती है उसके बाद व्हाट इस
वो खतरनाक है तो रियल लाइफ में अपने ऊपर
करके बताया
आप लोग अपने बड़े में कितनी इनफॉरमेशन
पब्लिकली अवेलेबल है कितनी इनफॉरमेशन मिली
अवेलेबल नहीं है वो आप लोग अपने ऊपर कर
सकते हो बट
मैं आपको यही बोलूंगा
की हम आपको लाइव में किसी की रियल लाइफ को
हम एक्सपोज करके दिखाएंगे तो हम ऐसा नहीं
करने वाले तो
आपको ऐसा लगता है की आपको ऐसा कुछ चाहिए
तो हमेशा नहीं करने वाले आप चाहे तो छोड़
सकते हो
सिखाओगे आप एडवांस पटना हूं पढ़ना हो तो
बात बुक सजेस्ट कीजिए
मैंने कल नेक्स्ट जो आपको बताया जो मैंने
आपको सिखाया यह आपका एक ऐसे लेवल तक है
इसकी बेस पर आप सरवाइव कर जाओगे मतलब काफी
अच्छा सरवाइव कर जाओगे अगर आपको एडवांस
जाना है तो फिर आपको वैसे तो बता दिया
जाएगा ₹900 एडवांस आने के लिए बुक्स
अवेलेबल है काली की ओरेकल की बुक्स वैसे
अवेलेबल है वो आप पढ़ सकते हो काजल अलेक्स
के ऊपर ओरेकल की उसकी बुक्स अवेलेबल है
एडरवाइज आप चाहे तो खाली की वेबसाइट पे
जाके भी उसका डॉक्यूमेंटेशन पढ़ सकते हो
उसमें काफी डिटेल में आपको सीखने को मिल
जाएगा खाली के बड़े में
आना चाहिए इसके लिए
ब्रो देखो भाइयों में दोस्तों मेरी बात
सुनो
इंटेलिजेंस में यहां ऐसा नहीं है की आपको
मैं कोई टूल उसे कर रहा हूं आप समझना की
कोशिश नहीं करें मैंने पूरा एक घंटे का
पूरा लेक्चर डिलीवर किया है आप लोगों को
की ओपनटेलिंस क्या होता है क्या मैंने
कहानी पर भी यह भी आपको शब्द उसे किया की
ये नहीं ये ओनली पेन टेस्टर के लिए है या
किसी साइबर सिक्योरिटी है मैंने क्या बोला
एवं आप अपने पेरेंट्स को भी बोलिए वो इसको
रेफर करें उसे इन वीडियो को देखें अब मैं
ऐसा बोल रहा हूं तो इसमें किसी भी प्रकार
की नॉलेज की जरूर नहीं है आपको इसमें सब
आपको आम सेंस की जरूर है आप बोल सकते की
आम सेंस आप में कितनी है की आप डेली बेसिस
जो गलतियां कर रहे हैं उनको होने से कैसे
रॉक सकते हैं समझे
ग्रेट एक्सपीरियंस ओके थैंक यू
ओके
ज्यादा हो शक्ति है लेकिन वो तभी होगी जब
आपका लाइव वेट ज्यादा होगा हमारा
सब्सक्राइबर बदहवाओगे सब कुछ बढ़ेगा तो ही
वो आपके लिए हम आपके लिए कुछ ज्यादा और
ज्यादा डिलीवर कर सकते हैं क्योंकि हम आप
लोगों से फ्री ट्रेनिंग डिलीवर कर रहे हैं
और आप लोगों से बदले में हम क्या मांग रहे
हैं सब एक छोटी सी चीज मांग रहे हैं लाइक
कमेंट और सब्सक्राइब यही चीज मांग रहे हैं
और बाकी उन लोगों को भी लेकर आई
जो लोग सच में सीखना चाहते हैं जिनको
सच में ज्यादा जरूर है जिसके पास अगर कॉपी
पर कॉपी पेन है ना तो प्लीज ए जाइए
एटलिस्ट उन्हें नहीं है नुकसान नहीं होगा
अगर वो टूल उसे नहीं कर पाएंगे नहीं लेकिन
उनको यह चीज सीखने को मिलेगी की क्या
इनफॉरमेशन उसको डालनी चाहिए क्या
इनफॉरमेशन उसको रखती चाहिए कौन सी
इनफॉरमेशन नहीं रखती चाहिए
10:00 बजे
मैं बस मजाक कर रहा था
उनके साथ प्रैक्टिस कर सकते हैं
[संगीत]
आई डोंट नो की आप लोगों को एक छोटी सी चीज
समझ में नहीं ए रही है की ओपन सोशल
इंटेलिजेंस इसमें किसी डाटा एनालिस्ट किया
किसी का भी रोल नहीं है इसका सब इसमें हर
एक इंडिविजुअल का रोल है यह चीज आप छोटी
सी एक आम सेंस वाली चीज आप लोगों को क्यों
नहीं समझ में ए रही है आई डोंट नो
ओसियन सबके लिए
[संगीत]
हो रहा है
जो चीज आपके सामने प्रेजेंट में चल रही
होती है तो प्लीज आप उनके फॉक्स कीजिए ना
पहले पहले आप उन लोगों
की हमारी प्रॉब्लम यह है की
हम क्या करते हैं ना की जो चीज चल रही है
उसको नहीं सीखेंगे
वापस उसे चीज को सीखने के लिए
क्योंकि आप एक रोड में फॉलो नहीं कर रहे
भाई मैं हम क्या कर रहे हैं
ऊपर से नीचे तक जो पुरी में जो टीम है
आपको जी तरीके से डिलीवर कर दिया उसे
पोस्ट को पूरा एक रोड मैप से डिलीवर हो
रहा है पूरा एक रोड मैप से और आपको ऑडियो
किड इनफॉरमेशन आपकी पेन टेस्टिंग की जर्नी
स्टार्ट हो रही है और करवा चुके हैं
लाइनेक्स से आपके पेन टेस्टिंग की जर्नी
हमने स्टार्ट कर दी है ये भी सेकंड पार्ट
ऑफ रोड मैप का पूरा रोड मैप मैं आपको पूरा
आपको एक रोड मैप मिलेगा यहां पर वो रोड
मैप से आपकी ट्रेनिंग चल रही है बट आप
लोगों को आई डोंट नो की समझ नहीं ए रहा
कुछ लोग अभी आए होंगे तो इसलिए पूछते हैं
सब कुछ आएगा
तो अब देखते हैं की कितने लोग एक्साइड हैं
कितने लोग एक्साइड नहीं है तो मुझे लगता
है
ज्यादा है ऐसे हैं क्वेश्चन जो
एलिमेंट है
अगर वह स्टैचू क्वेश्चंस आप पूछ रहे हो तो
और हां क्लासेस आपकी
स्टूडेंट हैं या आप किसी यूनिवर्सिटी में
कम करते हैं कोई प्रोफेसर है आप कुछ भी कम
करते हैं ताकि आप लोगों को वो चीज एक बार
दोबारा से देख कर रिवाइज करने का मौका मिल
जाए इसलिए आपको एक दिन का टाइम दिया जाता
है बीच में ताकि आपको अगर नोट्स बनाने हैं
आप खुद की कोई रिपोर्ट बनानी है तो आपको
क्या कर सकते हो बना सकते हो इसलिए एक दिन
छोड़ के एक दिन हम क्या करेंगे
कल क्लास नहीं आएगी दे आफ्टर टुमारो क्लास
बिल कम से टाइम
टाइमिंग
ओके
मैं पहले कोर्स नहीं किया
तो
जिन्होंने पहले काली का कोर्स नहीं किया
है तो प्लीज वह भी जाइए और उसको कर लीजिए
बट इसके प्रति नहीं है इस कोर्स को भी
कीजिए वह कोर्स आप धीरे-धीरे करते रहिए
एक-एक वीडियो करके देती है क्योंकि आपको
इन्फ्यूजन बहुत बेनिफिट देने वाला है जब
हम पेन टेस्टिंग भी सीखेंगे तब ओके तो बात
करते हैं अब ये हम करते हैं सेशन को और
मुझे लगता है की आप लोगों को कोई
क्वेश्चंस है तो
प्लीज आप लोग इसे रिक्वेस्ट है आज की जो
वीडियो हुई है आज की जो क्लास हुई है जो
इंट्रोडक्शन क्लास थी हमारी उसको सबके साथ
शेर कीजिए अपने दोस्तों को अपने फैमिली
मेंबर्स को सबको इधर लेकर आई सबको वह
दिखाइए सबको इसके बड़े में एजुकेटेड कीजिए
ताकि वह कब इन फ्यूचर कभी भी किसी भी
साइबर क्राइम का हिस्सा ना बन पे यार खुद
अपने आप को प्रोटेस्ट कर पे ओके तो जैसे
ज्यादा इसको शेर कीजिए लाइक कीजिए कमेंट
कीजिए सब में हमारी प्लेटफॉर्म को सपोर्ट
कीजिए ठीक है तो बस मैं यही जाऊंगा आप
लोगों से आप हमें सपोर्ट कीजिए सबको लेक
आई यहां पर ये यहां पर मैं आपको बोल रहा
हूं की कोई लिक्विडिटी नहीं है जीरो से
लेकर आप एक ऐसे लेवल पे छोड़ दिया जाओगे
जहां पर आप ओपन सोर्सेस इंटेलिजेंस कर
दिया यहां पर किसी को ये रिटायरमेंट नहीं
है की मुझे लाइनेक्स आना चाहिए मुझे साइबर
सिक्योरिटी देनी चाहिए मुझे हैकिंग चाहिए
कुछ नहीं आनी चाहिए अगर आप एक बैंक में भी
कम करते हुए कुछ भी कम करते हो आई और
सीखिए आपको हमेशा ये पुरी लाइफ टाइम हेल्प
करेगा खुद को प्रोटेस्ट करने के लिए ओके
तो आज का सेशन एंड करते हैं बाय बाय गुड
दे
co4 नेक्सस